nobody likes one more day all right
let's try this again
I better not die embarrassingly walk you
still bitching [ __ ] and out of here
[ __ ] ain't nobody got time for that I
really like Team four stars videos and I
don't talk about that enough but you
know Dragon Ball Z abridged is great in
fact I would you know I can't wait for I
kind of don't want to watch Dragon Ball
super because I'd rather see what safe
with you know the abridged version of it
is like when they get around to it which
I'm sure will piss off a couple of
Dragon Ball fans out there that's okay
Wow rag doll I felt like a helicopter
please please stop shooting me for five
seconds make you think I was gonna say
for [ __ ] sake but I didn't oh wait I
get it
damn it ah
alright this is getting ridiculous could
you guys like chill out for a second I
think I saw a guy floating above some
helicopter blades for like three frames
there just stop
I just want to living my life in peace
goddamn cops always coming down on a
black folk us black alien focus some
space there actually in this game you
may see your partner's dad it was
whatever venom is better as an alien
okay and carnage is cooler in the
original universe and and Mary Jane is
better and Mysterio is the same material
for some stupid reason oh god please
don't let me die again just cut me a
break you guys war where civilians did
they evacuate the city because of the
whole venom thing we're the Avengers
people should be here for this hey look
here's a person come back you you've got
a delicious skeleton there let me taste
it my dig venom tongue there you guys
excited for edge of venom verse I have
no idea what the hell to expect anymore
from
and denom comics there's so all over the
place
it's another character that they clearly
didn't have any idea what to do with for
a little while and then as soon as they
gave Flash Thompson suits like it had
some direction again and then and then
he got nerf in the guardians of the
galaxy thing and then became like a
space pirate and that was cool I like
that when he was alone in space the
space Knight they called it them young
children but then they took the black
suit away from Flash Thompson again and
it's just like way I haven't read the
new venom comics but I have a feeling
that they're going to be kind of aimless
and dumb just because it's one of those
things like as soon as you have kind of
[ __ ] up the status cool for a
character like that it's going to take a
while to have any idea what to do with
it like like when scorpion was venom
that was interesting for like five
minutes when it was introduced and then
after that it was just like alright
where do we what do we do with him next
and then they put him in the Dark
Avengers and it's like alright he's
going to be evil spider-man for
Osbourne's Avengers okay and then after
that and then after that they ran out of
ideas and we're like alright we have to
give it to a known new host again hey I
think I beat the mission guys [ __ ] you
Chapas
hey they reuse this thing construction
site familiy of the fresh familiar those
back tentacles looked like cool like you
should use those for something nothing
nothing sexual mind you just like you
could do like a doc Ock's thing and be
spider-man Apple tomorrow you know I
think venom is like kind of easy to just
turn into like a hentai monster and I
don't think that's the intensity of
creator all 70 of them but um yeah
actually
someone should google that and go tell
me how that how that works out because I
I feel like that exists I'm - I'm -
cowardly to go check
stop your tank Mary I can't tell if I'm
killing the helicopters or not there's
no explosion they just disappeared like
all my friends joking say oh yeah no one
knows who technically created Venom's
because it's like it's a combination of
ideas from like 16 people because like
the guy who came up with the idea of a
living costume was originally going to
give it to iron fist and then didn't and
then Spiderman adopted it liked that
idea in Secret Wars so there's the guy
who came up with the black suit or the
guy the guy who came up with living
costume anyway and then the guy who came
up specifically with the black suit and
then there's the guy who came up with
venom although that's under contention
because like some guy was like alright I
have this idea Marvel pay me for it
spider-man's black suit leaves and then
goes and hooks up with someone else and
becomes a villain
and they paid that guy a bunch of money
not not a lot of money but some money
for that idea and then and then someone
else specifically came up with the idea
for venom like Eddie Brock and I
remember also I read somewhere that the
original version of Eddie brought of
like venom was a woman who who I guess
was on the way for like she was on the
way to the hospital to give birth and
she was like driving with her husband's
tissues and labor and then like I think
like a taxi driver was distracted by
seeing spider-man swing by or something
and then hit their beside their car and
both her baby and her husband died and
then she's like she came upon the black
suit and was like I'm gonna kill
spider-man and that sounds real neat but
then they're like now let's just make
him let's just make venom a guy and Saad
McFarlane was like ours okay it'll be
like black suit spider-man but bigger
and then for no reason I'll just put a
bunch of keys on him and you know what
the rest is history
oh yeah
Todd was also the first person
technically to draw a venom and I I
think other people came along and did
that design better when they're like all
right instead of like a joker smile it's
going to be like jagged shark feet I
just like the evolution of these
characters because they say it takes so
much to get them to be as cool as they
are now or as they were at some point
because some of them aren't as cool
anymore Ben Riley
we may have lost Eddie Brock but we
still got Peter Parker
[Music]
yeah [ __ ] your weird Helicarrier ripoff
thing you guys suck city gold of course
all right let's go see five consecutive
attacks let's go demonstrate that on the
street nice I like that uppercut token
yeah that's cool
look at these kicks
look at these sick kicks I can do look
how cool I am everybody if only Flash
Thompson could see me now hey ever
notice how Kenny Kong is like a
self-insert character for Brian Michael
Bendis like like that's just what Kenny
Kong Harlem is like you guys noticed
that I'm not crazy am I like there it's
kind of kind of obvious all right
hey so another question was like dude do
people people ask me if I like like
really classic spider-man written by
Stan Lee and I don't know I think I
actually kind of prefer as a book Mora
to Jerry Conway started writing it you
know the guy who created Punisher and
jackal and stuff like that guy he was
only 19 when he took over writing for
the book and he he really rocked it like
good job on that guy like and then after
that you know Peter David who everyone
go check out my interview with comic
writer Peter David from Comic Con
because I think that's one of my like
least watched videos and one of my
favorites too like I love that one I
want to I want to go ask him more
questions again next year if he shows up
at Comic Con I'll ask him questions
about Romanian and see if he killed me
God willing he will anyway uh then um
there was like there's so many comic
writers from the 80s who did a really
good job with spider-man stories that
it's kind of hard to name all of them
and some of them only wrote for maybe
like two or three issues but they kicked
at like J and a mop ie the guy who wrote
Cravens last hunt I probably answered
this question before I don't know why
I'm repeating myself jammed a mop they
did some kickass stuff like I loved all
that stuff with vermin like those really
dark storylines or he wrote most of the
stuff from when Harry Osborn became the
Green Goblin he also introduced the
concept of the Clone Saga or he's one of
the people working on that and I think
it's kind of unfortunate that it went
the way it did I don't specifically
blame him for it
I think I think the Clone Saga is no
one's fault I think it's just just a
thing that happened and I'm glad it's
over raw glad it's over
I wish Jane Parker was still around he
was cool unless he got revived and I
wasn't aware of it
I should go goop that up but yeah
keikain is cool oh my god race metals
alright [ __ ] it let's go do a race let's
go do the race everyone let's go race go
let's go cross the bridge to go do races
are you a fan of races no I hate races I
am a race if oh god please don't isolate
that audio and use it like in a BuzzFeed
article popular youtuber Godzilla
Mendoza
openly admits these are races more at 11
you see the problem with that is that I
said the word popular
10,000 is a small but respectable
fanbase I I'm living on Deadpool numbers
now and that that's fine by me [ __ ] what
am I looking for races yeah that's it
all right uh jeez did I do all them
alright there's more over here I not do
these ones in the city how is that
possible
alright we'll go do this one next let's
go everybody
ooh tokens boy I'm gonna I'm probably
gonna you know 100% complete this game
like off-screen just because I have
nothing better to do with my time and
also don't like myself very much I'm
gonna do all those Human Torch races
because I'm a masochist I mean I played
like two or three of them and I don't
remember them being that hard but it was
also a couple years ago I might have
snapped a controller in half over them
and then forgot about it what game
should I let's play next and and I
promise the upload schedule will not be
the same as for this series oh [ __ ] but
like what I don't a lot of people been
saying yeah do like spider-man web of
Shadows met that game's considerably
longer but I'd be I'd be willing to give
it a try I like that game and also like
if you don't think of a non spider-man
game because I want to just be like a
spider-man channel like I want to be
like the general all-purpose comic-book
guy you know that's why I reviewed
Batman Arkham Knight and why I'm going
to review like Marvel Ultimate Alliance
and maybe a digital name but I don't
want to just skip stuff being like only
a spider-man game channel because that's
kind of like I don't know that's not
very inclusive that's like you'll only
be interested in watching my stuff if
you played spider-man video
at one point so uh in fact I just get
kind of bothered by the idea channels
that are like just slavishly devoted to
one topic only like people who are like
yeah I'm going to only talk about five
nights at freddys or whatever well
there's the first human torch race like
if that's your favorite game then fine
but people aren't going to want to keep
watching once that series is over or
like you know what if they just don't
announce the new five nights at Freddy's
game then you're going to have to rely
on doing something else and you got to
pray that you're interesting enough that
those fanatics hands will stick around
after you stop talking about their
favorite things and I think that kind of
applies to like spider-man fans like I
know someone in a comment said on part
eight of the spider-man game
retrospective woke time dawn subscribe
because I'm only here for your
spider-man game reviews and I like I
don't think you realize how [ __ ]
offensive that is to me as a creator
because I like making more than just
those kinds of videos and then he went
on to go say please make more spider-man
reviews so I can stay subscribe to you
do all the movies next and then do
reviews of all the Marvel movies until
ungrateful little [ __ ] anyway alright
review every [ __ ] I want just for you
told you superhero conspiracies calm
it says someone's going to mutant it or
not and in some do calling some
speedball the coolest things is the
ultimate and this is going to haunt you
yes yes it is
keep reading whoa guy named or PB says
that's the one the librarians have
secretly developed a bio tactical legion
uh-huh that sounds a whole lot like the
guy that smacked me around last night
well there you go then geez librarian
session what we're doing busting in the
lab doing things
I should go check it out or we could go
to the movies hold on I'm not a call
rooftop now hey you guys wanna talk on
Enochian right now I kind of do
this is my wife good this is a real
intrusion I need you to back off the
librarian thing why sorry kid
eighteen and older why not me it means I
need you to back off yeah okay fine fine
this is my life don't come here thanks
kid
general do you think he'll behave
knowing Peter Parker the way I do I'm
absolutely sure that he will do the
exact opposite of what I just asked him
to do all right let's go piss off a
thority because that's what teams do
18 and over how does he think he is
ah great
hey how you doing Bobby
like right now then again it has been
almost two hours in the last year for my
life oh boy this Jenny one whoa okay
he's fast yeah that's well that's just
great
least the timings perfect that I could
probably defend this part right here I'm
going to have a lot to say about Green
Goblin next part um both the original
and ultimate version and yeah I'm
excited it's it's it's going to be it's
going to be cool give me because this is
also like one of the coolest boss fights
in the game and arguably the most
difficult so you know get ready to watch
me get my ass kicked a lot see you next
time Dan Slott ruins everything